on the eve of the midterm elections the
president has issued one more threat to
people who are planning to vote
illegally today or who have already been
voting illegally early they're gonna get
you is what Donald Trump is saying this
is Trump continuing the farce because
that's what it is of pretending that
in-person voter fraud is anything or the
other than Republicans trying to test
the system and often getting caught
check out what Donald Trump tweeted
yesterday quote law enforcement has been
strongly notified what the hell does
that even mean to watch closely for any
illegal voting which may take place in
Tuesday's election or early voting
anyone caught will be subjected to the
capitalised maximum criminal penalties
allowed by law thank you let's
understand the reality here and by the
way this is a good opportunity to
mention I didn't literally mean
yesterday when I did my story about how
fact-checking Trump is an exercise in
futility
I didn't literally mean we shouldn't
talk about the truth or falsity of what
Donald Trump says but my point yesterday
was to get Trump supporters to abandon
him pointing out that he lies isn't
really a good strategy since they don't
actually care about the truth and
they've been primed to disregard the
truth when it conflicts with their view
but there is of course still value in
discussing how the world really is and
the world really is one where in the
United States an election commission was
created by Donald Trump when he said
three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton in the
2016 presidential election that voter
fraud commission his own voter fraud
commission run by the truly horrible
Kris Kobach found no evidence of voter
fraud and then the Commission was
disbanded almost a year ago very quietly
even though we reported on it and you
barely heard anything about it since
other than the fact that Trump still
insists that these illegal votes are
actually a problem what do we know about
voter fraud in this form in this
in-person style what we know is that the
cases are most
of Republicans who say I'm gonna prove
to them how easy it is to show up and do
voter fraud and they get caught because
it is against the law
and it's not actually that easy to do
and of course Donald Trump talks
endlessly about people double registered
and people registered to vote but
meaning people registered to vote in two
places people voting for dead people and
all of the stuff first of all as I've
said before and I know I'm a broken
record on this being registered in two
places just isn't a problem and it's not
against the law as long as you're not
trying to vote in two places that's
number one
I was registered for a while in at my
old address and my new address but I
never actually tried to go and vote at
both so it's no problem but then of
course it turned out that the people
around Trump themselves actually did or
had associated with them a lot of the
characteristics that Donald Trump said
we should be concerned about so as an
example stephen Bannon was registered
somewhere he didn't actually live
Trump's own son-in-law Jared Kushner was
registered as a woman and I know at the
time all the sorts of jokes were made
about it it's an error but it's it's a
it's an incorrect voter registration
Trump's daughter Tiffany Trump was
registered in two places so his usual
Pat when Trump pushed the three to five
million people voted illegally thing
either
he was knowingly lying or he had fallen
into believing the conspiracy theory
himself in the end it doesn't matter
although I believe that he does believe
it because reports are he talks
privately about this as well it's not
just stuff he tweets about and we didn't
need Trump's failed voter fraud
commission to know that this just really
isn't a significant issue the Brennan
Center for Justice took a look at this
something like fifteen years they took a
look at a billion votes and there were
only maybe twenty thirty cases of voter
fraud I think part of the reason for
that is just because the penalty for it
is so severe I mean you can go to jail
for five years you can get fined $10,000
now many people are willing to do that
over just one seemingly inconsequential
vote it's not a big problem indeed
indeed and and by the way it's also
important to mention that they have this
amazing circular reasoning
where they say tons of people are doing
this and then you say exactly what you
just said 1.3 billion or however many
votes were accounted for
twenty-something instances they'll say
well that's because the people doing it
aren't getting caught but then they go
to do it to show how easy it is and they
get caught so ii believe what they're
saying you have to believe that the
undocumented immigrants the people on
the Left who are doing this in at a
scale of millions of votes are way more
skilled at doing it than the Republicans
who seem to get caught every time and if
that's your argument you have to explain
why like why are the people on the Left
who are doing the illegal voting able to
get away with it when the people of on
the on the right seem to keep getting
caught and I haven't heard a good
explanation for that so bottom line
Trump's lying about voter fraud he's
lying about the immigrant Caravan and
it's sort of secondary whether these are
deliberate lies or whether he believes
this trash the way that his own
supporters do it only matters if people
value the truth and as I told you about
yesterday and I got a lot of positive
feedback about that story and some
people who misunderstood it they don't
right now the truth is not valued as a
pillar of political honesty and ideology
and that's why we need numbers and
simply to get more people voting than
them and we'll know very soon whether or
not we got that this time around I am
really thrilled to tell you that one of
today's sponsors is a service that I
personally use myself called simple
habit and you can get a free trial at
simple habit comm slash Pakman it is
really important to take a break from
Twitter to take a break from the
inundation of politics and media and
Trump and all of the stuff that's going
on and a really great way to take that
break and sort of do a mental reset is
with simple habit a guided meditation
app that just won the 2018 Google Play
award for best well-being app perfect
for people with busy lifestyles you just
need five minutes a day
they have morning meditations
meditations for going to sleep
meditations for
dealing with headaches stress
meditations for athletes for fighting
procrastination for promoting creativity
they have a huge catalogue of hundreds
and hundreds of meditations for almost
anything you're trying to accomplish and
you can use the app to track all of your
progress they also have music you can
listen to that's designed specifically
to keep you calm and focused while
you're working or reading go check it
out you can try it free for seven days
at simple habit calm slash Pakman I've
put a link underneath this video